welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and recently a disney insider
conference call confirmed that despite
mulan's shift to a streaming release
marvel's black widow is still set for a
theatrical release and falc winter
soldier and wandavision remain top
priorities for disney plus
so whoo other than the release dates the
plan marvel head kevin feige announced
at comic-con last year
is still mostly a go a plan that if you
remember also confirmed the x-men in the
pipeline there's no time left to talk
about
mutants
yeah because he burned all that time
letting black swan pose with a hammer
that's been destroyed in this canonical
timeline
whatever in the months since we have
been speculating exactly what feige
meant by how mutants are coming into the
mcu
a multiverse collision of end to the
mind of scarlet witch in one division
gamma radiation from one of those snaps
creating mutants in this world
the more reasonable possibility that
they're all already there we just
haven't met them yet
or a deadpool toeing in everybody
through a portal with professor x's
wheelchair
all are equally valid possibilities but
you know rather than putting
all of those x chips on one upcoming
phase four title
like introducing dozens of mutants in
one movie a new
more obvious likelihood just occurred to
me after our
rewards folks we probably already know
exactly how kevin feige likes to
introduce a long lineup of new faces he
already has a proven success formula
that i'm now willing to bet he's gonna
use again
it's so obvious that i kind of blurted
it out in a recent episode of rogue
theory is t'challa
to this neighbor storm rory monroe i
actually think
each phase four title could introduce a
different mutant in the mcu that'd be
really fun okay i can actually pinpoint
the second in my sleep deprived eyes
where i was like
holy [ __ ] duh why haven't i been
pitching this the whole time think about
it a decade ago kevin feige didn't start
with the avengers he took
years and years of sprinkled in easter
eggs and iron man
incredible hulk iron man 2 thor and
captain america and
then he unveiled the full lineup
together while phase
4 has i think 11 announced films
seven announced live-action streaming
series none of them x-men
in title but each of them an opportunity
to gradually introduce the mutants
at feige's famous addie to frame pace
sprinkled in that exercise yard a
handful out of time
until mainstream audiences are caught up
with the nerds and boom
portal card to a new franchise we all
love 3 000. so here is my hypothesis
as our recent rogue theory episode
speculated for storm in black panther 2
and rogue in captain marvel 2 every
single one of the upcoming mcu titles
will introduce
at least one mutant or have a mutant
reference as was the case with the
avengers in phase one the first
sightings will be easy to miss snuck in
just for us
nerds like a name shout out or a clue on
a background screen
or surface then once we're all onto this
hunt later titles will more overtly cast
mutants as supporting characters in the
plots
building up to their lineup in a future
team-up film with
x-men or mutants in the title so let us
start with the two streaming series
coming later this year
rogue theory recently explored falcon
winter soldiers casting reports for
yakuza biker gang members
and images on biker jackets from that
set with a demonic face that looks a lot
like hogan an
x-men villain with ties to wolverine and
kitty pride
shadowcat really as a series likely to
explore the legacy of captain america
part of that history was the weapon x
attempts to replicate the super
soldier's success
next one division is almost certain to
feature wanda's mutant children billy
kaplan
wiccan and tommy shepard's speed maybe
also her mutant brother quicksilver
maybe also their mutant father eric
lynch or magneto
why not they're all very important in
the house of m story that looks like
it's partly influenced by onto black
widow still on the discussion for
november part of it will go down at a
russian
prison this could be an opportunity to
explore another russian mutant duo
peter rasputin colossus and his sister
ileana magic
colossus was one of the older generation
x-men who debuted in 1976 alongside
wolverine
and storm and his sighting of him could
be as simple as alexi turning to his
inmate neighbor and saying
rasputin help me with this door but
before i continue thanks to
bang energy for sponsoring this video
every can of bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine it's
sugar-free and it has
zero calories
yet it tastes great with over 20
different flavors to choose from this
one that's really really close to my
face is called purple haze and it tastes
like purple which we know is a fruit
it's delicious fruit it's like grape
soda but like not as much sugar and will
wake you up more
gulp check out bang on instagram you can
get 25
off your order at bang energy.com when
you use the code newrockstars25
there you can buy cans of bang energy
including their sweet tea and keto
coffee flavors
you can also get clothing fitness
supplements all kinds of stuff to be
your best
bang self thanks again to bang energy
for sponsoring this video
get 25 off your order at bang energy.com
using the code new rock starts 25. okay
on to loki it will feature the time
variance authority marvel's time cops
the bureaucrats who untangle all of
marvel's complex timeline midland
one of their cases has gotta be that of
nathan summer's cable that guy
loves screwing with timelines just a
name on a case file be plenty to
establish deadpool as canon also please
the eternals will be set partially in
ancient times a perfect opportunity to
establish the biblical origin of mutant
kind with
apocalypse shang chi is an interesting
case because as i explained in last
week's video it's looking like a huge
international fighting tournament which
really could set up cameos by any
number of eclectic mutant ring fighters
we're talking wolverine
sabertooth the blob nightcrawler
juggernaut and the hawkeye series that
is moving forward with writers and
directors
in the comics he does briefly work with
a mutant firestar in the thunderbolt run
but i'd kind of like to see a marksman
like clint teamed up with scott summers
cyclops
spider-man 3 now moved to december 2021
could introduce peter's other
collaborator from his amazing friend
series
bobby drake iceman who is a younger
mutant who was speculated to be part of
peter's next story during those
sony disney negotiations last year thor
love and thunder
is bringing back the physicist jane
foster and if we do explore her in her
academic community it could be a way to
work in some brainiac colleagues of hers
like
dr jean grey dr hank mccoy beast and if
we're already on the cosmic side of
stuff
why not the phoenix horse too and for
doctor stranger the multiverse of
madness the favorite idea i've heard for
the post-credits scene
would be for strange to visit a
colleague of his up in westchester
county
charles xavier planting the seeds for
marvel's illuminati now black panther 2
is a great place for storm i explained
why in rogue theory but also since
neymar is technically a mutant like they
called him a mutant at some point
if he does tie into the plot he could be
another example of a mutant and yeah
many are speculating captain marvel 2 to
introduce a rogue
mutant who in the comics gains her
flight and strength powers by touching
carol danvers but also with carol's
connections in louisiana i would love it
if they use that to introduce
remy leboue gambit dreaming series moon
knight will follow mark spector in
egypt which i think will be a great
setting to introduce the evil mutant the
shadow king amal farook
who has egyptian origins and took a
terrifying form in legion on fx
miss marvel kamala khan is rumored to
first appear in captain marvel 2.
in the comics she teams up with
wolverine and cyclops at different
points but really i like the idea of her
befriending mutants like x-23 laura
kinney
blink maybe psylocke she-hulk looks to
me like a legal procedural
mixed with action and that way any
number of jennifer walter's clients
could be
vulnerable on the run mutants ones like
angel jubilee
ant-man 3 has also been announced which
i still believe will be the gateway for
the fantastic four and doctor doom but
if sue storm were to be pregnant their
child
is omega level mutant franklin richards
now sometime in the future will be
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 which i
have said before could establish
sinister associate high evolutionary as
part of rocket's origin story
and of course mahershal ali's blade
reboot is still in the works he did join
the x-men in the curse of the mutant
storyline but i think it'd be fun to see
him cross paths
with the underworld gang of mutants the
morlocks now of course there are even
more mutants i really want to see
brought in the mcu
bishop darwin banshee marrow warpath
and the ones from the recent new mutants
film mirage cannonball sunspot wolfsbane
eric voss's havoc
i'm just kidding i'm holding out for
beyonder let me know what you think
about this theory and join our nerdy
discussion on our official discord
server by becoming a patreon at
patreon.comrockstars follow me on
instagram
avos follow new rockstars and subscribe
for breakdowns of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you